[Musique]
bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 17
septembre merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition de votre journal
d'information on commence tout de suite
avec les titres de l'actualité
locale nouvelle mobilisation des
enseignants contre la réforme du collège
la 3è depuis la présentation du projet
par la ministre ils étaient à Paris
aujourd'hui nous entendrons leur
revendication le président de
l'Assemblée nationale délaisse le
perchoir pour rentrer en campagne pour
les régionales en île-de-fance il était
avec les candidats yelinois en
déplacement cet après-midi il a
rencontré les ingénieurs de l'INERA
Versailles et plus de 1500 événements à
travers la France ce dimanche pour la
journée du cheval les ivelines terre
ipique nous verrons ce qui vous attend
avec nos invités William kgel fondateur
du hara de la sence et Sandra bon
directrice du centre équestre de l'Î de
loisir bonsoir à vous deux merci d'être
venu sur notre plateau nous reviendrons
avec vous dans quelques instants sur
cette journée et une information tout
d'abord pour ouvrir ce journal
concernant la ville de Plaisir 50
caravanes s'y sont arrêté une
quarantaine de familles se sont
installées sur le parking de la Société
des affectés Hau sur la zone
industrielle des gaâtines installé ici
par manque de place cette situation
serait tolérée par la mairie cette
communauté de gens du voyage viendrait
de la commune de vieille église il
devrait reprendre la route autour du 30
septembre et l'actualité d'aujourd'hui
c'est la manifestation des enseignants
contre la réforme du Collège des
Enseignants yvelinois y ont participé
ils se sont donné rendez-vous ce jeudi
dans le 5e arrondissement de Paris pour
manifester leur colère et demander
l'abrogation pardon de cette réforme
David charpontier était sur
place tous réunis contre la réforme du
collège de Najad Valo Belkassem
aujourd'hui ses professeurs ont répondu
à l'appel de la mobilisation lancée par
les différents syndicats rassemblés au
jardin du Luxembourg ils n qu'un seul
mot à la bouche le M d'ordre il estclair
c'est l'abrogation du du décret tel
qu'il a été publié et puis des arrêtés
qui ont qui ont
suivi il
semble semble évident que et je pense
unanime de la part de la communauté
éducative qui est nécessité de faire une
réforme mais celle qui nous est proposée
nous
semble incongrue des revendications
auxquelles des parents d'élèves prennent
part comme cette maman venue de
Versailles depuis ce printemps je suis
très mobilisée contre la réforme
puisqu'elle va supprimer les les options
bilang et euros ma fille est en 5e
option bilangue et à cause de cette
réforme elle va être privé l'année
prochaine de la la section européenne
germanique pourquoi pourquoi priver ces
ces élèves d'option disparition des
classes bilingues interdisciplinarité
autonomie accrue des établissements les
faiblesses sont nombreuses selon les
enseignants c'est leur première
manifestation depuis la rentrée au mois
de mai un premier appel à la
mobilisation avait réuni environ 30 % de
riste la dynamique s'était essoufflé au
mois de juin avec seulement 20 %
d'enseignants mobilisés la mobilisation
aujourd'hui vous voyez qu'elle est là
elle est présente elle est autour de
moi il y a des enseignants qui malgré le
contexte de début d'année scolaire
chargé avec la reprise des cours avec
les réunion parents professeurs sont là
en masse c'est un premier début selon le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale 15,8
% des enseignants sont en grève ce jeudi
sur toute la France pour protester
contre la réforme des collèges dans les
ivines 6,40 % des professeurs se
seraient
mobilisés et nous sommes en ligne avec
Delphine Romanie du SNES 78 Delphine
Romanie on parle de 15,8 % d'enseignant
en grève au niveau national et 6,40 dans
les ielines votre réaction c'est peu
vous attendez à ce résultat-là Delphine
Romanie alors je pense que la
communication du ministère c'est un
petit peu la même que celle qu'elle nous
a faite au printemps et au mois de juin
c'est-à-dire que elle cumule euh les
enseignants de collège et de lycées et
on fait la mobilisation est
majoritairement en collège et en plus il
calculent leur chiffrees sur le
pourcentage de professeurs dans
l'établissement alors que celui qui est
réel c'est celui de professeurs attendu
c'est-à-dire ceux qui ont cours le jeudi
matin euh mais sur place qu'avez-vous
constaté sur place la la mobilisation
était là selon vous vous êtes satisfaite
alors c'est une grève de rentrée
c'est-à-dire que on a une mobilisation
qui est en cours de de préparation on a
eu des établissements où il y avait des
fortes mobilisations par exemple au
collège Renoir de châou euh non pardon
au collège paulbert de Chatou on avait
19 enseignants sur 25 en grève donc il y
a des établissements la mobilisation est
déjà forte euh il y a des établissements
où elle l'a été un peu moins euh mais où
on commence à nous solliciter pour venir
et pour préparer la manifestation du 10
octobre et justement avez-vous le
sentiment d'avoir été entendu vous avez
été reçu par le gouvernement alors ça
j'ai pas encore les informations c'est
un petit peu tôt pour le dire euh je
pense qu'on pourra le dire un petit peu
plus tard dans la soirée très bien et
bien merci beaucoup Delphine Romanie
prochaine action donc le samedi 10
octobre nous suivrons cette actualité
merci de nous avoir répondu je vous
merci au revoir au revoir et toujours
concernant l'enseignement dans les
Yvelines l'académie de Versailles a un
nouveau recteur Daniel filatre a été
nommé la semaine dernière en conseil des
ministres il a pris officiellement ses
fonctions hier et succède à Pierre Yve
Duvois Daniel philatre est professeur de
sociologie il était recteur de
l'académie de Grenoble depuis juillet
2013 il fut de mai 2012 à juillet 2013
conseiller en charge des formations de
l'orientation et de l'insertion auprès
de l'ex-ministre de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche jeuneveve
fiorasso et un mot concernant les
régionales Claude Bartelone le président
de l'Assemblée nationale désormais
officiellement en campagne pour les
élections régionales d'Île-de-France
était aujourd'hui à Versailles le
candidat du Parti socialiste s'est rendu
à linra l'Institut national de recherche
agroalimentaire pour constater les
recherches des chercheurs français
William l et Camille
Lambert une journée placée sous le SIG
de l'agriculture avant de rencontrer le
réseau AMAP Île-de-France Claude
Bartolone le candidat du Parti
socialiste aux élections régionales
d'Île-de-France était aujourd'hui à
Versailles en visite à liner pour
observer l'avancée des recherches dans
le secteur agroalimentaire on voit ce
que représente la recherche en
Île-de-France par rapport à l'Europe
puisque nous sommes la première
plateforme de recherche et donc voir
comment la région Île-de-France peut
venir dans le cercle vertueux au côté de
l'État pour pour à la fois aider ses
chercheurs penser les métiers et les
industries qui feront la richesse de la
France demain les emplois et son
activité ça me paraissait quelque chose
d'extrêmement important c'est aussi le
moment de s'imprémier des problématiques
là en l'occurrence de la recherche de on
a parlé beaucoup là des des doctorants
des des postdog donc on est avec des
échanges concrets et c'est de ça dont on
a besoin aussi pour être au plus proche
en terme de solution ensuite de des
demandes et de la réalité du terrain une
visite qui vient constater le bilan de
Jean-Paul Huchon président sortant et
les aides apportées par la région à
l'Institut pour penser au futur
renforcement du secteur mais aussi
aborder la question des transports on
voit les différents outils qui sont ceux
de la région sur lequel il faut activer
utiliser le bilan de Jean-Paul Huchon
pour aller plus loin et l'on voit bien
sur la réflexion de ce que peut-être le
métro du Grand Paris ce que
représenterait la desserte de sa clé et
pourquoi pas de versaill est de 50 ans
en Eveline si comme je le souhaite nous
obtenons les Jeux olympiques de 2024
rassembler les franciliens et les
convaincre c'est maintenant l'objectif
affiché de Claude Bartolone avec le
lancement de sa campagne dont les
grandes orientations seront dévoilées
fin
octobre et toujours en politique le
député desvines Jean-Frédéric Poisson
président du Parti Chrétien déémocrate
fondé par Christine Boutin vient
d'officialiser sa candidature à une
primaire à droite pour 2016 en vue des
présidentielles dans les colonnes de
l'hébdomadaire conservateur valeurs
actuelles en kiosque depuis ce matin il
justifie sa décision par une volonté de
porter de nouvelles convictions justice
sociale conditions de vie culture
chrétienne ou encore racine de la France
il portera aussi son doute l'idée d'une
abrogation de la loi ouvrant le mariage
au couple du même sexe loi qui l'avait
ardemment combattu on se souvient
également que Jean-Frédéric Poisson
s'est illustré cet été en rendant visite
au dictateur syrien Bachar al-Assad il
n'a pas été possible de le joindre
aujourd'hui mais il sera l'invité début
octobre du café politique sur TVfil
78 et nous parlons maintenant équitation
avec plus de 700 licenciés la Fédération
française d'équitation et la 3ème
fédération sportive en France derrière
le football et le tennis le 20 septembre
les centres équestres et les poney clubs
de France ouvre leurs porte en plateau
pour en parler avec moi William krigel
fondateur du hara de la sens et Sandra
Buron directrice du centre équestre de
l'île de l'ISIR alors tout d'abord une
première question que représente cette
journée pour vous c'est un rendez-vous
qui est annuel où les gens commencent à
prendre l'habitude c'est le même weekend
que la journée du patrimoine donc c'est
un rendez-vous qui commence à être un
petit peu plus connu pour tout le monde
donc ça permet de de finir de faire
découvrir notre activité pour préparer
les les activités de la rentrée puis qui
vont perdurer sur toute l'année scolaire
CR c'est une façon aussi de faire
découvrir leur R de la sens parce
qu'avant vous ouvrez vous ouvriez pas
forcément vos portes au public pour les
rencontres de la sens c'est ça alors les
rencontres de la sens existe depuis 15
ans donc c'est pas une nouveauté par
contre euh on en étant au même date que
la journée porte ouverte pour les pour
les clubs et pour les cavaliers on fait
donc l'entrée de dimanche gratuite et on
a organisé la journée d'animation de
dimanche autour de thématique de
découverte de partage et d'initiation
donc on invite les familles les enfants
les adultes à venir à monter sur des
chevaux à toucher et à découvrir
l'thologies est-ce que l'objectif c'est
de donner je sais pas une image
peut-être nouvelle une autre image de
l'équitation peut-être que celle qu'
qu'on a
am alors je pense que d'abord on a une
bonne image de l'équitation parce que
l'équitation est est un art noble euh
c'est un art noble mais certains pensent
que c'est un petit peu onéreux la
noblesse et le et le coût de de l'usage
est n'est pasèement lié je pense que
c'est pas siur que ça parce que un
cheval est un animal vivant qui demande
de l'entretien qui demande du travail
euh avoir des professionnels de qualité
demande de la formation donc on peut pas
imaginer que tout ça soit entre
guillemets gratuit par contre quand on
voit les prix pratiqués par les centres
équestres ou par des gens comme nous euh
je pense qu'on a des prix abordables et
justement l'île de loisir voilà c'est
faire découvrir à peut-être amener
d'autres des des enfants en basâge
peut-être aller vers l'équitation d dès
le plus jeunâge nous on propose comme
activité les baptêmes poney qui ont lieu
déjà tout au long de l'année alors la
différence c'est que sur cette journée
là ils vont être gratuits donc là on
ouvre aux enfants à partir de de 2 ans
après ça nous les cours commencent
uniquement à partir de 4 ans est-ce que
vous avez peut-être moins d'inscrit
depuis les événements de de la crise
justement les françaistion le budget on
fonctionne pas comme un C classique qui
a des on vient monter pendant une heure
donc on est plutôt un centre de
formation et on n pas eu de base
d'activité réelle par contre on a eu des
des recentrages d'activités donc il y
avait des gens qui ven faire des stages
pour une semaine qui viennent pour 3
jours des choses comme ça mais
globalement il y a pas de B d'activité
réelle la raison c'est qu'en fait
l'affectif lié au cheval est extrêmement
fort l'envie de venir avoir une relation
avec le cheval est extrêmement fort la
crise aussi douloureuse soit-elle
n'enlève pas ces envis là auadlence
l'éthologie est au cœur de votre
approche avec le cheval monsieur le
cavalier vous nous en parl tout à
l'heure est-ce que vous pouvez
m'expliquer ce qui est l'éthologie alors
l'éthologie de façon simplifié c'est la
science du comportement des chevaux des
animaux enfin là je suis dans Je
ramèneie au cheval mais il y aie pour
les chiens et cetera donc c'est
l'observation de l'animal la philosophie
la manière dont on envisage les choses
c'est que on veut partir de l'animal et
ensuite monter dessus si jeose dire donc
on essaie de comprendre comment
fonctionne l' animal on a bien compris
ça parce qu'il y a des scientifiques on
fait de la recherche donc on étilise des
recherches des scientifiques on est nous
dans l'application on n'est pas
scientifique et on offre aux gens la
capacité d'apprendre pourquoi un animal
un cheval se comporte comme il se
comporte il se comporte pour des raisons
extrêmement précise en fonction de ce
qu'il est donc si on apprend et on
comprend comment il se comporte on est
beaucoup plus en sécurité on a plus de
plaisir et on arrive à faire une bien
meilleure acitation dans un meilleur
respect de l'animal qui est très
important San aussi vous faites
attention à l'éthologie c'est quelque
chose qui qui est dans la pratique dans
l'apprentissage pour vos cavaliers alors
ça en fait partie surtout depuis la
réforme de des galots donc où il y a une
partie maintenant Gal ce sont les les
les B entre examens pass examens
fédéraux qui marque la progression de de
niveau donc oui depuis que l'éthologie
de toute façon a été mise au programme
on en voilà on l'officialise avec ce
terme là après je pense que quand on est
des gens de chevaux et qui enseignant
l'équitation on fait tous à notre niveau
une forme d'éthologie puisqu'on apprend
à connaître les chevaux pour pouvoir les
utiliser sous le sens positif du terme
pour apprendre aux gens à monter à
cheval et à prendre plaisir à cheval
donc et qu'est-ce que ça change
concrètement dans
l'apprentissage jeun je prends une
vision un peu simple artique et
traditionnel on va et on monte sur un
cheval si on essaie de vivre avec le
cheval on se rapproche de lui sur un
plan horizontal d'abord à pied on
éventuellement on lu fait faire quelques
mouvements de motricité et cetera pour
que le cheval réagisse avec vous et
ensuite vous montez dessus donc on on
parle de la compréhension de l'animal
c'est très très important et en le
comprenant on le respecte mieux et on a
une meilleure acitation très bien et par
rapport aux activités que vous proposez
vous proposez aussi le caroussel donc à
l'île de loisir il y a aussi des
activités pour faire découvrir d'autres
façons de faire du cheval aux enfants ou
aux gens qui seraient intéressés bah on
essaie sur cette journée là en fait de
faire des démonstrations un petit peu
plus ludique et et plus visuel pour pour
les spectateurs justement pour ceux qui
sont pas forcément euh très très aguéri
dans la connaissance de l'équitation le
but c'est de pouvoir venir en famille
aussi pour découvrir différentes
activités et le carousel effectivement
en fait partie euh voilà c'est c'est une
prtique déplacement un
déplacement une une chorégraphie en fait
qui est réalisée en musique avec avec un
thème les cavaliers sont déguisés sur
sur le thème donc là il y en aura
effectivement deux dimanches un
carrousel adulte sur le thème d'Obélix
Astérix et Obélix et un carousel enfant
sur le thème de disco vous proposez
aussi des activités par exemple comme du
horsebll ou des poney Games pour
peut-être les gens qui ont peur du saut
d'obstacle ou du dressage comme on peut
le connaître alors on a du Pony Games on
a plus de horse ball on a fait mais à un
moment on peut pas trop diversifier ses
activités non plus donc on a du Pony
Games effectivement et puis du dressage
pour les gens qui peuvent avoir peur de
sauter ou tout simplement les gens qui
aiment le dressage alors de la sence il
y aura aussi des conférences pour
vraiment ceux qui veulent voilà
s'informer sur l'éthologie alors on a on
a organiser notre weekend sur 3 jours
donc vendredi samedi et dimanche
vendredi c'est une conférence sur le
thème du du cheval équitation éthique et
éthologie avec une série de
d'intervenants de grande qualité qui
représentent des gens de la société
comme Axel Cann qui représentent des
scientifiques ou des ou des étologues
comme Manan roche mais aussi des grands
cavaliers des entraîneurs des
représentants de la Fédération Française
ch le compte président de la Fédération
sera
là le président le le grand écuiller du
Cadre Noir ser là donc en fait on a une
population si je dire extrêmement
diversifiée sur un une thématique qui
est le bien-être du cheval et qui est
donc une thématique à la fois sociétale
puisque l'animal aujourd'hui bénéficie
du noix pour protéger son statut et en
même temps d'un cou remporteur sur le
plan affectif et les gens sont
extrêmement demandeurs de ça samedi on
est dans une journée où on est beaucoup
plus proche de l'équitation donc c'est
c'est équitation sportive équitation de
loisirs et éthologie avec des des grand
entraîneurs et des professionnels et
dimanche on est beaucoup plus dans une
journée grand public avec de la
animation de la démonstration mais
l'initiation peut venir s'initier
découvrir toucher autour de ça on a
pendant ces 3 jours un salon du livre
équestre où il y a une librairie en fait
avec à peu près 700 livres différents
qui sont tous liés à l'ques donc c'est
une opportunité d'avir tout en même
temps c'est extrêmement agréable donc
c'est un c'est c'est un grand nous
devons nous arrêter là malheureusement
c'est un grand c'est un grand événement
voilà si vous êtes passionné de cheval
d'équitation si vous voulez découvrir
n'hésitez pas donc soit vous rendre au
har de la sence qui je rappelle à
Rochefort en Yveline ou à au
centrequestre de l'île de lois ir à
Saint-Quentin en Yveline merci à vous
deux d'être venus sur notre plateau je
le rappelle la journée du cheval c'est
le dimanche 20 septembre donc il y aura
des animations dans tous les centres des
centres échestres et les Poney Club de
France tout ce weekend plus d'infos sur
le site internet journée du cheval tout
attaché.fffee.com en France 65000
personnes sont aveugles et près de 2
millions sont atteintes de malvoyance à
Buc un centre d'élevage et d'éducation
de chiens de guide a été construit
l'association chien de guide de Paris
Est à l'initiative de ce nouvel
établissement qui sera inauguré ce
samedi Fanny Bourdillon y est allé avant
son ouverture à la rencontre de ces
chiens souvent indispensables pour le
remettre berger labrador ou golden
retriever les chiens du nouveau centre
de Bu sont sélectionnés pour leur bon
sens de l'orientation et leur très bonne
vue les éducateurs les stimulent ensuite
pendant un an et demi l'objectif
développer et aiguiser leur sens pour
assurer au mieux la sécurité de leur
futur maître on va avoir des des skates
des trottinettes voilà plein de de
petits objets pour pas qu'ils aient peur
c'est important parce que sinon si une
fois qu'ils sont grands sils ont peur je
vois qu'il y a un skate qui passe dans
la rue ça peut être ça peut être super
embêtant donc voilà donc on les habit
tout petit ah ça les
éclate seulement 1 % des personnes
malvoyantes ont un chien guide pour en
recevoir un le temps d'attente est long
entre 1 et 2 ans mais la patience en
vaut la peine le chien bénéficie de
nombreux avantages par rapport à la
canne le chien guide va amener une
aisance dans le déplacement un plaisir
un plaisir de se déplacer qui qui qui
n'est pas là avec la Cann il va amener
aussi de la sécurité il va permettre
d'éviter des obstacles que la Cann ne
peut pas détecter et aussi c'est un
attrait social qui est qui est très
important les gens vont venir voir vont
venir voir le chien avant de venir voir
la personne et et comme ça les personnes
font des rencontres l'association chien
guide de Paris remet 40 chiens tous les
ans avec en moyenne 150 naissances
prévues pour cette année le nouveau
centre d'élevage permettra de réduire
les délais d'attente il ouvrira ce
samedi 19 9 septembre à
Buc et comme chaque jeudi dans le
journal le point sur les rendez-vous
sportifs du weekend aujourd'hui c'est
avec Wilfried Richy bonsoir wilfreded
bonsoir Floran l'actualité sportive
nationale qui est plutôt chargée he pour
les prochains jours entre les
basketteurs français qui affrontent
l'Espagne ce soir pour une place en
finale de l'Eurobasket leurs homologues
en rugby et qui débutent leur coupe du
monde samedi face aux Italiens on en
oublierai presque qu'en local il y aura
la reprise du championnat de National 1
en handball handball féminin bonsoir
Philippe l'étrange vous êtes
l'entraîneur des féminines justement on
va rappeler brièvement l'histoire la
saison dernière vous aviez terminé la 3e
place en Nationale 2 impossible
d'accéder au barrage Le Havre s'est
désisté la suite on la connaît passer la
surprise la joie d'accéder à la
nationale une est-ce que vous êtes prêts
est-ce que les filles sont prêtes ben
j'espère parce que je crois qu'on a bien
travaillé vous avez travaillé pendant
tout l'été euh les filles avaient un
programme à faire tout l'été on a repris
le 17 tout donc voilà et la reprise ce
sera face à Landy lampul c'est une
équipe bretonne c'est une équipe
bretonne qu' qui était avec nous il y a
2 ans h et qu'on retrouve c'est une
équipe accessible j'espère des points
forts des points faibles vous avez dit
c'est une bonne équipe qui a qui joue
bien au ballon qui est bien solidaire
qui fait bien tourner la balle donc il
va falloir les perturber de ce côté-là
et puis j'espère qu'on sera la hauteur
en National une cette année vous allez
affronter Rennes angoulem Nantes est-ce
qu'il y a des équipes qui vous font peur
bah il y a des équipes qui je vont jouer
le haut de tableau donc je pense pas
qu'on soit de ce niveau-là maintenant
j'espè non non non non non on a le temps
l'objectif c'est objectif c'est le
maintien déjà dans un premier temps
incorporer les jeunes pour péréniser ce
maintien puis après peut-être voir
audessus mais bon dans le détail pour
votre équipe il y a eu des arrivées des
départs pendant l'été en fin de saison
dernière vous étiez venus sur ce plateau
pendant le le 7 h sport et vous aviez
évoqué la possibilité de de de recruter
des ailiers par exemple enfin renforcer
un petit peu certains postes avec des
joueuses des joueuses de qui avaient
déjà de l'expérience de ce voilà donc on
a recruté trois joueuses une gardienne
qui a déjà joué même en donc qui est un
peu âgé qui va être aussi son travail ça
va être de former notre jeun gardien de
16 ans euh on a recrouté une demiente
qui évolué en National 1 l'année
dernière et puis une arrière gauche qui
évolué en National 2 mais qui a joué en
en Division 1 r en Roumanie h et donc
qui renforce plus toutes les jeunes qui
montent donc ça fait un groupe de 20 à
21 filles donc c'est c'est très
intéressant un mélange entre
l'expérience et puis le vivier de la
jeunesse avec les les jeunes du du club
je voudrais pas rappeler d'histoire
douloureuse mais la montée en National
une montinil Bretonneux en H féminin l'a
déjà connu ça s'est pas forcément passé
très bien puisque la redescente a été
immédiate et quasiment tous les matchs
ont été perdus bah oui de toute façon il
y a un gros palier là entre la Nationale
2 et la Nationale 1 donc il va falloir
être de niveaux surtout un niveau
physique je pense qu'au niveau hand bal
on a on a de quoi répondre maintenant
c'est l'intensité physique tout au long
de la partie qui va falloir répondre
présente et et vous leur dites quoi
vousos jouees actuellement de surtout
pas s'inquiéter même si les premiers
matchs sont difficiles il faut garder
confiance parce que la mécanique quand
on commence à perdre ça difficile après
de relancer la Mach compqué donc
j'espère le le début de championnat
peut-être va nous permettre de gagner un
ou deux matchs pour nous lancer ça
serait bien enganger la confiance voilà
pour engranger la confiance après les
grosses écuries bah ne pas être trop
ridicule et puis après on verra tout au
long de la saison peut-être avec des
remises en question certain moment et
puis a la concurrence au poste oui oui
il y a en gros trois filles par poste
donc c'est intéressant mais même si il y
a beaucoup de jeunes donc parce que le
budget de Montini ne permet pas d'avoir
des des filles à fort rendement donc
mais la forma les jeune c'est
intéressant pronostic pour ce match pour
cette reprise à domicile face Victo on
va pr l victoire non non les les
victoire je pense pas qu'il y en aura
beaucoup cette année mais une victoire
ou ça fa du bien ou du bien merci
Philipe ltron je passé en plateau alors
que samedi se déroulera donc ce premier
match de la saison pour votre équipe on
voit la date samedi 19 20h30 complex
Pierre de Coubertin merci encore pour
terminer un mot de foutues Floran
puisque le calendrier de D1 vient d'être
dévoilé les Templiers d' lancour vont
affronter en ouverture le flash de la
cour neuve ce sera lors du weekend du 6
février on a le temps la saison commence
tardivement c'est une rencontre qui sent
tout de même le souffre à domicile face
à un club champion neu fois champion et
5 fois V champion depuis le milieu des
années 90 ils étaient encore en
demi-finale l'année dernière alors que
du côté des lancour c'est plutôt la
reconstruction avec l'arrivée d'un
nouveau directeur sportif pendant les
vacances de cet été merci Wilfried le
prochain rendez-vous sport c'est lundi à
18h30 avec Michel elmidoro pour le setfi
sport ce sera en direct qui reprendra du
service qui reprendra du service et
voilà il revient de vacances justement
et pour refermer cette édition un mot de
patrimoine dans les années 60
l'urbaniste et promoteur Jacques Ribou
imagine la ville de demain contrairement
à de nombreux architectes de son temps
qui ne g que par les villes nouvelles
jacqu Ribou conçoit le projet fou d'une
ville à la campagne d'une ville heureuse
ce principe sera expérimenté à grande
échelle à Villepreux et longcour mais
aussi morpa pour donner une âme à ses
rues l'urbanisme fait l'urbaniste pardon
fait appel au sculpteur Gérard Ramon ses
œuvres sont exposées jusqu'au 3 octobre
dans la galerie marchande de Paris
wouest Maxime
lumen sur un rond-point ou devant
l'hôtel de ville les œuvres de Gérard
Ramon font partie de l'ADN de morpa le
but qu'avait Jacques Ribou c'était qu'il
fallait qu'on fasse de ses constru neuve
des choses humaines et qu'avait déjà une
âme on est donc il fallait avoir des
sujets comme des maternités comme des
des des des des jeux
d'enfant des choses simples que les gens
se retrouvaient quand les soir ils
arrivaient il retrouvaient des
sculptures qui étaient mises en place
qui étai pas des sculptures de musée en
fait c'était des sculptures pour la
ville au cœur de l'exposition la
sculpture des hibis restauré grâce à un
appel au mécénal lancé en 2012 par
l'association morpa d'hier et
aujourd'hui cette sculpture on la
retrouvait plus on savait qu'elle était
abîmée qu'elle avait été mais on ne la
trouvait plus et c'est lors d'un atelier
d'histoire que nous l'avons retrouvé et
lorsque nous l'avons retrouvé on s'est
dit il faut que l'on fasse quelque chose
il faut qu'on la restaure selon la
Fondation du Patrimoine l'appel au
Mécénat Populaire a permit de récolter
plus de 14000 € grâce aux donateurs les
ibis ont retrouvé leur apparence
d'origine un non de travail un vrai
challenge il y avait plus de coup il y
avait plus de tête donc c'était de
penser au
niveau un peu créateur c'est-à-dire
j'étais obligé de suivre les idées de GG
les hibises sont faits en cuivre donc on
est obligé de faire des des ossatures en
cuivre donc plein et après de
modeler suivant les les la petite
maquette donnée par
monsieur Ramon en bronze en cuivre ou en
acier les sculptures de Gérard Ramon
s'exposent jusqu'au 3 octobre dans la
galerie marchande de Paris Ouest à morpa
l'artiste sera également présent au
salon comparaison au Grand Palais à
Paris à partir du 24 novembre
prochain et c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de nous avoir suivi demain
vous retrouvez Wilfried Richy pour le
journal du vendredi pour ma part je vous
retrouve lundi à 18h pour une nouvelle
édition de ce journal en direct je vous
souhaite donc donc un très bon weekend
et une bonne
[Musique]
soirée